N
HAVE THEIR VEHICLE CONTROLLED
AND TURNED OFF BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
ARE VOTERS FOR THIS.
JENNY -- JIMMY IS RUN AGAINST
HIM IN OHIO.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A FRINGE
POSITION.
IS IT IN OHIO?
>> I DEFINITELY THINK IT IS.
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
THIS IS TERRIBLE FOR OHIO
CONSUMERS.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DRIVE
WHATEVER CAR THEY WANT TO.
THIS IS AMERICA AND PEOPLE HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO CHOOSE.
IT'S A MASSIVE CLASS WAR AGAINST
OHIO AUTO WORKERS.
WHY THAT SHOULD THEY BE PUT OUT
OF A JOB BECAUSE TIM RYAN DONORS
WHO OWN THE ELECTRIC CAR
COMPANIES WANT TO GET RICHER?
THAT'S NOT REPORTING THE PEOPLE
OF OHIO OR MIDDLE-CLASS.
BUT TIM RYAN IS INTERESTED IN
REPRESENTING HIS DONORS WHO FUND
HIS FRAUDULENT CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS IT ALWAYS
BANNING?
SAY I WILL MAKE A CAR SO GREAT,
YOU WILL WANT TO BUY IT.
WHY DOES TIM RYAN GO TO MAKING
IT ILLEGAL?
>> BECAUSE HE KNOWS HIS
PREFERRED GREEN ENERGY FANTASY
WON'T HAPPEN THROUGH FREE
CHOICE.
UNLESS THE GOVERNMENT FORCES
THIS ON PEOPLE, NOBODY WILL GO
FOR IT.
TUCKER, THIS IS WHY PEOPLE NEED
TO SUPPORT MY CAMPAIGN.
WHAT HE IS DOING IS TRYING TO
TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY.
WE CAN'T LET HIM DO THAT.
>> Tucker: AND PRETENDING TO BE
A WORKING MAN VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE.
IT'S INSULTI